this is a production of cornell
university
all right hello everyone welcome to hemp
411
um we are so thrilled that y'all have
joined us today
so
my name is zach stancil i am the usda
hemp germplasm curator so we're based in
geneva new york
um there's a little bit of sunlight and
a little bit of warmth here so spring is
coming in geneva
um
and what we do here is we run a seed
library for hemp so we we collect hemp
from all over the world
store it grow it out in our
greenhouses
and collect seeds we gather a lot of
data about those different varieties of
hemp and then we make those different
varieties available
to the hemp research community
for free
so we're trying to
conserve the genetic diversity of hemp
and then make that available to help
science and industry and
you know a whole cadre of different
people who are working with hemp
um
so we hope that this that our work here
will allow these universities companies
farmers and really everyone to benefit
from him in the next 10 20 30 years
um
also while we've been doing this work
we've met so many awesome brilliant
creative people kind of across the whole
uh spectrum of hemp
and we really want to share them and
their knowledge with you
i want to tell you about hunter
friedland who is our speaker today
so hunter is the founder and ceo of
serona labs which he started while he
was studying at
cornell university
after conducting a study of the hemp
supply chain in new york state
in conjunction with the national science
foundation
he saw an opportunity to develop a
higher standard
for cannabinoid ingredients
since then he has assembled a
world-class team of top scientists
and
consumer-packaged goods experts
and successfully secured initial
fundraising rounds
to ensure the company is set up for
long-term growth
hunter is passionate about the cannabis
industry and is dedicated to help
building an innovative and equitable
industry in new york
so
in addition to his role as the ceo of
sirona labs
he has recently assumed the
processing and manufacturing committee
chair role for the new york cannabis
growers and processors association
so without further ado i bring you
hunter
thanks so much it's a pleasure to meet
everybody and thank you for having me
so yeah today you know i'm going to talk
a little bit about food science and on
entrepreneurship in the hemp and
cannabis industry give you a little bit
of a background of how i started the
company you know where we're at today
and some of the pain points that are
posed in the industry i'm going to keep
this pretty casual so feel free to kind
of ask questions during the lecture and
i'll try to get to them during the
lecture or
um after
so yeah without further ado i'll start
by just talking a little bit about
a little bit about functional beverages
i think this is a good way to kind of
give everybody a general background of
you know the history of the industry
where it started you know where we think
it's going with the emergence of
cannabinoids as a really great
functional ingredient
to create new specific mood states so
no generally functional beverages is a
large market right you can see here
estimated that it's going to be almost a
400 billion dollar global market by the
end of next year with 56 percent of
consumers having tried products that are
trying to
beverage products or trying to
focus on specific health conditions or
specific mood states
um you know the way that we look at this
market is really starting with the
emergence of red bull in the energy
category so in the late 90s and early
2000s red bull you know was the first
player in this market started in
thailand was brought by i believe a
dutch company or german company
to europe and you know really started
nightclubs where people started using
red bull
and then a major consumer package goods
company uh came to europe saw how this
product was doing and started to bring
that to the us and you know since then
functional beverages and energy drinks
make up a huge huge category in the us
around that time you saw you know the
emergence of vitamin water where you
have vitamins and beverages protein
beverages um you know this you know
canal with kombucha and stick packs
things like liquid iv so you're seeing
the development of this category
starting where you know consumers are
looking for you know meat states and
really functional ingredients and
products that you know have different
uses for different times of the day
so you know that's kind of where we're
at today you know as this market starts
to emerge you've seen startups enter the
space as well as major consumer packaged
goods companies like molson coors and
pepsi and constellation you know jump in
so you know over the past few years as
the cannabis industry has gained more
steam and cbd has gained more regulatory
clarity you've started to see you know
an emergence of
cbd and other cannabinoids as a
functional ingredient to drive mood
states so you know where again like we
talked about before products like red
bull and protein protein drinks are used
for things you know cannabinoids have
the ability to
early days in terms of research but have
the ability to drive these specific mood
states for example cbd being more of a
general wellness ingredient you're
starting to see the emergence of
research around minor cannabinoids a
cannabinoid like cbn that has thought
and has potential use cases for sleep or
cbg which is thought to have use cases
for energy you know in conjunction with
these other ingredients so you know as
this category starts to evolve we're
going to see you know major companies
like the constellations and pepsi's and
folks in this world start to use these
ingredients
to drive again more mood state specific
products right now the landscape of
cannabinoid infused beverages is mostly
startups you're starting to see
some of the larger consumer package
goods and companies enter the space but
due to you know what i'll talk about a
little bit later the regulatory
environment today you know the major
multinational cpgs are not uh really you
know pushing forward in this space just
yet
so yeah right now i'll just kind of give
a little bit of a background of how i
started the company you know where we're
at today um and then kind of go through
our team and talk more about our
specific pain points that we're solving
in the marketplace where customers are
and know what's different about what we
do
but um you know again i'm hunter
friedland i started this company in kind
of early to mid 2018 while i was a
senior at
cornell university starting getting
involved in industry you know kind of by
happenstance a few people in my life my
girlfriend's grandfather
my dad's friend had hemp farms
across new york and one in oregon
so i started learning about the industry
this is all pre-2018 farm bills so
pretty early days in space but started
learning about the space start to see
that there looked like a lot of
opportunity and generally a lot of
interesting opportunities in the space
so started pushing forward started uh
ultimately reaching out to a few
professors at the university that's
where i got in touch with larry smart as
well as a professor called ali abazor
who worked in the hemp research
department and the emulsion science lab
at cornell so that was really my
introduction to you know what is
happening on the science side and where
are the main points so
from connecting with the university it
was around the same time that
applications for the second round of
hemp processing licenses opened up in
new york state
so we ultimately applied uh for one of
these licenses and again late 2018
and uh you know started kind of pushing
forward you know at that point after we
made that application we applied and got
into the national science foundation
icorps program
so that whole program is about solving
pain points and working with you know
unique technology and how you bring that
to market and what are the real pain
points that we're solving at that point
you know we were really early in the
development of the company
and the initial business model was all
around extraction so we started pushing
forward and really connecting with
anybody in the market that would have a
conversation with us across the supply
chain but particularly the licensed hemp
farmers in new york so we talked and had
conversations with the vast majority of
farmers in new york state
we did 20-minute interviews to
understand really what were their pain
points everything you know at the time
from just a general lack of
infrastructure right everything from
drying to that extraction but then you
know actually sales points um you know
got a really good overview of you know
who the players were in the market
and um and where we could drive value to
the marketplace so shortly after that
the farm bill passed um and that made
hemp legal in all uh in all 50 states at
least at the beginning of that
transition so that was a really exciting
moment and shortly after the passing of
the farm bill we received one of the few
licenses the process had under the
research partnership agreement
in in new york state i graduated a few
months after that and just myself
started kind of going to conferences and
you know again keeping pushing forward
to see where do we fit in in this
marketplace and initially after you know
doing the nsfi corpse program we
determined that extraction was a major
pain point in the market right it was
very limited infrastructure in new york
state and kind of acting as this
clearinghouse taking hemp farmers
product and turning them into a usable
ingredient for a variety of consumer
packaged goods products um seemed like
the best place to start to build a
business but
after a few months of going to
conferences really getting a bigger
understanding of what does this market
look like beyond just new york state but
really across the us we saw that
extraction was starting to become more
of a commodity business there was no
real ip that we could develop around
that side of the supply chain and we
started to take the pivot towards
formulation which i'll talk a lot about
you know in this uh in this lecture
today
but that was around the time that i met
two of my three co-founders i'll talk a
little bit more about after this but
nick who is a phd in food science from
cornell uh who formerly worked at canopy
growth one of the largest cannabis
companies in the world joined the
company um and we started kind of
pushing them towards formulation where
there's a general big problem uh with
cannabis cannabis in general by nature
is an oil and oil and water don't mix so
how do you create products like
beverages
or confectionary products that during
the manufacturing products process have
mainly a water base
so we kind of pushed towards that and
started developing solutions around
really spray dried powders and emulsion
technology which the basic concept is
taking a big oil particle and making it
a really small stable nano emulsion um
and i'll talk more specifically about
these pain points as we move forward but
started you know pushing towards
that problem in the market um ended up
raising our first round of funding uh
where that was the end of 2020 where we
raised our first round
and got up and running out of our lab in
geneva new york we are located in the
cornell tech farm which is pointing out
as the incubation space for food and ag
startups i mean that's where our whole
business is based today
so with that said i will start to move
to the next slide
and just talk a little bit more about
our team um and then we'll talk more
about the business but and i gave you
guys generally my background i went to
cornell i studied hospitality so it
didn't come from the agriculture or or
the hardcore sciences but they studied
the hospitality business in school
graduated and started you know started
this business but nick is also a
cornelian he has a food science phd from
cornell he graduated in 2009
i believe
and after his phd he went to work for a
company called constellation brands
constellation brands is one of the
largest beverage alcohol companies in
the u.s that owns and distributes brands
like corona beer or robin bobby wines he
worked there for about eight years in
research and development and after uh
his ten years were there constellation
made a large investment company called
canopy growth which at the time was the
largest canadian cannabis company in the
world
and nick was tapped as the first person
to run their r b department so he led
the team like commercialized the first
cbd and thc beverages in the canadian
market
and as well as launching their general
2.0 cannabis products so products like
edibles and vapes and infused pre-rolls
and topicals
so that was kind of nick's background i
did that for three years and then joined
us as a co-founder in the business
allen joined around the same time
allen's our chief operating officer he
comes from a food beverage and alcohol
background working mainly for a company
called the destree food and drink which
is based out of rochester new york
pedestrian is one of the largest
contract manufacturers in in the us
meaning they manufacture products for a
variety of different brands and
companies so a company like pepsi could
go to a company like pedestri and have
them manufacture a variety of their skus
and i think that's kind of a
misconception that people you know see
in the cpg industry that all these
companies are manufacturing their own
products but they're actually businesses
called co-packers that manufacture for a
variety of different companies
and create a much more efficient supply
chain that way so alan worked at
ledestri for around 25 years ended up
running a 350 million division there
where he ran the whole co-packing
division worked with companies like
gorilla heinz pepsi monster
and etc throughout his career
left in private equity for a few years
and then joined us as the chief
operating officer
and then and he's co-founder and the
four of us including lj are the four
co-founders and lj is the candy man we'd
like to call him his uh family was the
friera pan candy company which was one
of the largest candy companies in the
u.s before they exited in 2017 the
company owned and operated brands like
lemonheads fireball trolley gummy bear
black forest gummy bear
at the time of exit they represented 70
of the gummies on the shelf in the
convenience store besides harebo so you
know really one of the global players in
the um in the candy industry so after 30
years there they exited to ferrero the
makers of nutella and
then lg started making investments in
the cannabis industry he went out to
california and
ran an edibles the company out there
before joining us as the chief
innovation officer so those are the four
uh co-founders in the company i'll
quickly go through the rest at this
point we're a small kind of close-knit
team but really you know which i'll
emphasize really hiring the best
is critical when building a business
particularly in this industry so quickly
cam is the chief commercial officer he
also comes from canopy growth he worked
at a variety in a variety of marketing
and sales roles at major cpg companies
like muslim cores and kellogg's
before ending up at canopy where he ran
their beverage department
on the marketing and sales side
saul is a phd chemist he worked in the
pharmaceutical industry after his phd
and then went to work for canopy growth
under nick working there for four years
before joining us
xavier or x
is our director of business development
he comes from la and worked in silicon
valley for five or six years and
in business development roles and sales
roles across a variety of venture-backed
startups from the incubator called y
combinator and after doing those sales
and business development roles he ended
up launching his own cbd beverage in
late 2018
that company ultimately failed but
learned tremendous amount by being one
of the first cbd beverages to launch the
market um and you know x runs biz dev as
well as all of our social impact
initiatives
so that is uh the team
let's see so yeah now we'll just talk
you know a little bit more specifically
about what we do um
as a part of the supply chain at seroto
labs and i'll talk briefly about you
know our parent company kings road
holdings where we're expanding into the
more traditional cannabis market in new
york
but you know starting from kind of get
go it all starts you know with the seed
right you have um your genetics that
drive what product you're producing
whether the genetics are going to
determine the reduced enhancement plant
or cannabis plant a variety of different
genetics that perform better in certain
environments and this is something that
that george and larry's team can tell
you about a lot more intelligently than
i can but that's where it all starts
after the seeds are grown into a plant
the plants are harvested and then in our
case collected for biomass where they're
dried
harvested and then sent to the processor
right so we're kind of sit in that
processing side of the supply chain
right initially and today we sit right
after the actual extractor but after the
biomass is harvested the biomass goes to
an extractor where it's extracted for
its active oil right so the cannabis is
used in a variety of different
extraction methods but most popular at
least in the hemp side being ethanol so
this solvent is used to extract
the active product in this case cbd or
thc or cvn
from the plant material into a more
concentrated oil format then it goes
through a distillation process to create
a distillate at that point you can
either use that as your core input or
isolate which is an isolated cannabinoid
so kind of taking your full spectrum
product meaning the full essence of the
plant including its terpenes and the
variety of cannabinoids that were
present in that plant material or
isolating one specific cannabinoid which
in most cases right now for pep industry
is cbd
so
that's kind of where we come in um as a
formulator in this space so we take the
inputs being isolated or distillate and
convert that into a water dispersable
product where we have ip which is kind
of our unique formulation in conjunction
with the active product we emulsify it
and to create you know again these very
small
nanoparticles
that are then used to create stable and
efficacious ingredients for water-based
products in the industry
we have two kind of inputs it's either a
spray dried powder or a liquid emulsion
so once you have your input ingredient
whether that being a distillate or a
water-soluble product like we produce
you get into the commercialization
manufacturing process right when you're
taking these ingredients and
manufacturing a variety of products like
beverages or gummies or vapes um and
that is uh you know kind of what that
co-packing business is and today we're
only doing the formulation work but as
we you know
move into the new york adult use
cannabis market we are opening up a
cannabis manufacturing facility where we
will actually manufacture the end
products for these other brands similar
to the business i mentioned before that
allen operated called the destroy so
it's you know again scaled manufacturing
you know operating as an efficient
operator
to bring costs down for a variety of
them at the brands in the market by
producing in one singular facility
so after the manufacturing process then
you move to retail where products are
then sold you know in the case of cbd at
a variety of different
places from online
to um to you know big box retailers or
convenience stores or on the cannabis
side of the market strictly being sold
at dispensaries um
at licensed dispensaries
let's move on to the next slide
so i will kind of talk generally about
the challenges on our side of the
marketplace right when you're taking
again a distillate turning it into a
water-soluble product at the end of the
day we're servicing food and beverage
products
and taste is king right if a product
doesn't taste good
consumers really do not want to use that
product and by nature cannabis is a
really bitter product a really bitter
ingredient so you know that's a
challenge that we've you know pushed to
solve and creating an ingredient that
can be efficacious that we'll talk about
in a second but uh you know it has
limited to no taste um at higher dosages
in the product so taste is a very very
important aspect of this industry
um
inconsistent efficacy right i think i've
heard you know i've said that word
efficacy for a while but you know what
does that mean in conjunction to you
know this
this market um it really comes down to
kind of two terms onset time and
bioavailability right how fast does this
ingredient get into the bloodstream once
it's consumed and at what level does it
get into the bloodstream um because you
can have you know like for example let's
just say a thousand milligrams of cbd in
an end product but if that you know cbd
doesn't actually get into the blood it's
not having an effect
in for that person uh that use case so
efficacy is critical uh and this again
something that we've solved and proven
by hard data which i'll talk about later
as we've shown through our
pharmacokinetic studies
compatibility is uh is the next piece
right as i mentioned cannabis by nature
is an oil and oil and water don't mix so
how do you create
you know a product that is stable
meaning once we've created our emulsion
how does that emulsion then stay into
the beverage
or water based product for a long period
of time without separating you know the
easiest way to kind of visualize this is
a salad dressing right you see the oil
and the base and salad dressing that you
know separated but as you mix it and
shake it it becomes homogeneous but
pretty quickly leaving on the shelf
maybe after 10 20 30 minutes an hour
it goes back to where it was before
where the oil and base are separated
so that's a huge problem you know in
this space if you're creating an
ingredient that is supposed to you know
be an emulsion be able to be mixed into
water
and then just be put into and packaged
in a can for example you can't have that
product separate over time because then
you're going to have an oil slick at the
top of the beverage and it's not a nice
experience for the consumer and it's a
less efficacious product so stability
and compatibility
are key
you know to kind of expand upon
that you know how we you know build our
emotions is by custom
based on the product type so for example
a coffee versus a tea versus salsa water
all have different chemistries by nature
of the product
so
one emulsion isn't necessarily going to
work for all of those different product
types so that's again how we produce our
emulsions here at stronan is a big
differentiator but i will talk more to
that
as the presentation goes on you know the
last two pieces are poor appearance
having a very cloudy emulsion um is
something that is not as appealing to
the consumer so how do you create a
product that is you know completely
translucent
but also has a minimal taste uh for the
end consumer and then lastly is
scientific validation you know
particularly a lot of our competitors in
the space kind of talk through you know
how fast onset time how great your
efficacy is but there really is no
evidence to back that up
so that's something that we take really
seriously here at the company and truly
backing our ingredients by science and i
will be showing you you know the results
from our first pharmacokinetic study
where we dosed rats and tested the
bloodstream over certain intervals to
prove how quickly the onset time was and
what the bioavailability of our
immediate is
compared to you know basic products on
the market
so you know just kind of giving a little
bit larger view of you know what our
solutions are i mentioned before we have
two products a liquid emulsion and a
spray dried powder
you know the main features are water
solubility meaning it can mix into water
and stay stable
they're fast acting
they have high bioavailability and
something unique about our ingredients
from a
label point of view is that we have no
preservatives in our products
we kind of hit multiple applications
where they're ingredients from beverages
to powdered mixes to topical products
edibles tinctures and pet products so a
wide range of product types that we can
power
as an ingredient supplier in this space
so you know talking more specifically
about our science and how the process
works as i mentioned before we start
with our active input call it a
distillate and isolate once that hemper
cannabis extract is required in the
facility we mix that with our
proprietary blend of emulsifiers and
surfactants that is kind of what our ip
covers you know at this point we're now
patent pending and after taking that
mixture of your emulsifiers and
surfactants in addition to
the active hemp material you then you
know use a variety of different
processes but the basic concept is high
pressure where you're taking you know a
machine as a diamond tip and really high
pressure to break these
particles into really really small
particles
while they're mixed with the unique base
to then create your nano emulsion right
so taking something from a really big
particle into millions of really small
nanoparticles that can now be easily
mixed into a water-based product as well
as having you know a faster onset time
as i've mentioned before
so talking a little bit more about our
pharmacokinetic study you know again we
you know really strive to
have you know real evidence behind our
ingredients here both from a stability
point of view but also from an uh
bioavailability onset type of view so
you know what we did last year is we
worked with a cro cro which is a
clinical research organization we work
with them to dose
rats with our ingredient and test their
blood at certain intervals so if you can
see on my screen the dark blue
line is our emulsion
the light blue line is what we call a
basic emulsion something like our
competitors use and the green line is
your basic oil tincture in the market
right taking a distillate and mixing
that with that or something like an
olive oil or mct oil
so we dosed rats with equal amounts of
product from um
with these three bases and tested their
blood and we were shown to have a much
faster onset of five to ten minutes
already showing up in the bloodstream
and around 30 minutes to what's called
the c-max which is the highest
concentration marked in the bloodstream
um for that ingredient that you're
testing for so as you can see here you
know our ingredient has a much faster
onset time and uh and and gets into the
flood stream at a much higher rate than
the oil tincture almost 5x uh the
highest concentration in in the oil
tincture uh our our ingredient achieves
and then compared to kind of a basic
emulsion in the market we have almost
twice as fast of an onset time
as the competition so
again we're you know continuing to push
this forward right now we're in work to
do a study in conjunction with some labs
at cornell and kind of moving from a rat
model to a dog model and then hopefully
soon in the future into human models
to continue to you know learn more and
develop more data around our
products let's see
so yeah maybe i'll kind of take a step
back and talk a little bit about the
regulatory environment you know
generally that is one of the things
holding this industry back the most is
the complicated structure of you know
how do you actually commercialize
products in the space
but to kind of take a step back it
really all started with the 2018 farm
bill that legalized hemp in all 50
states you know that really got this
industry started you saw a huge hype
cycle right after that
a farm bill passed with prices for raw
ingredients increasing almost tenfold
and then dropping more than that over
the course of a year and a half it was
you know quite you know exciting and
interesting time in the market
but with the emergence of that farm bill
we had a truly legal market where now
you could produce hemp products in one
state and as long as they're under 0.3
thc uh delta 9 thc they could be
then distributed and used in different
products
so you know that talks to the infused
products piece of things but you know
where we kind of move from the fda from
2018 farm bill is to the fda and the
fact that there's a lack of regulation
in the space right this is the major
reason why you see companies like coke
and pepsi and monster and red bull not
launching cbd infused products
is uh is the fact that the fda has no
regulatory structure around the industry
you know right now the only stance the
fda has taken is kind of giving warning
letters to companies that kind of abuse
the rules right making structure
structure
structure function claims you know on
cbd or other you know other cannabinoids
for example saying that cbd cures
covered or
cures or you know has specific
properties right those are things that
you're not allowed to do and you need
real evidence um and to go through fda
trials to back um that by real structure
structure function claims
but you know the lack of fda regulation
in general for food and beverage and
dietary supplement products and kind of
telling uh not telling the industry
operators how to produce products how to
distribute products how to label
products um poses a you know major issue
for the industry as it starts to expand
and bigger players start to
start to jump into the industry
so you know something that has developed
from the lack of fda regulation is
really state cannabis legislation so for
example
both in california and new york over the
past year
has regulated cbd in their specific
market so new york has their hemp
regulations that were released i believe
six or six to eight months ago um that
give clear pathway in terms of how to
operate um as a licensed entity and as a
cannabis pro cannabis and for your cbd
infused product on the shelf
they give clear limits on how many
milligrams you can use per per unit they
give a clear
process of what kind of
regulatory licenses as well as
compliance measures uh to have your
manufacturing operation for example you
know something very common in the
consumer packaged goods and co-packing
industry is a compliance measure called
current good manufacturing practices um
it's a process of tracking your
ingredients the supply chain tracking
your your products tracking how you um
produce products in your facility so
it's again compliance to make sure that
your ingredients you know have a certain
quality um and again are safe so
that is um
you know something that new york has
pretty clear regulatory structure around
and um
uh has created a clear regulatory
structure around it has allowed the
market to start to develop and grow in
new york state
so you know it's exciting and you've
seen similar regulations happen in
california with the passing of ab45
assembly bill 45 if anybody would like
to search that up after the
uh lecture
um state by state labeling kind of goes
hand in hand with state by state
cannabis legislation that's a big
difficulty in this space where it's
great that you're starting to see a real
regulatory structure that allows
operators to create a clear path
to commercializing products
with that different regulatory structure
from each state it creates huge
confusion for products right so maybe
you have a cbd tincture
in one state you may have a completely
different labeling require requirements
in another state so that really creates
a lot of inefficiency inefficiencies in
the supply chain and causes major
problems you know at the end of the day
maybe the last thing i'll kind of end
this off with is a delta eight and kind
of your hemp derived psychoactive
cannabinoids
so
it's delta eight and other similar
cannabinoids like thco or hhc
are isomers of
the cannabis plant so some of these
cannabinoids show up in the plant which
you have a very very small
uh my new percentage but there's been
you know chemical reactions in ways that
you can take products like the cbd
isolate and turn that into a product
like delta eight
so what delta eight is it's really kind
of a loophole in the language and the
farm bill where as i mentioned before
you know what constitutes hemp versus
cannabis is kind of this base number of
point three percent delta nine thc
active in the plant material
so delta eight is a different form uh
it's a different cannabinoid than delta
ix but has similar psychoactive effects
but due to the you know strict language
in the farm bill that specifically
states delta nine thc percentages is the
indication of cannabis there's now a
loophole for uh to get psychoactive
delta eight products that are derived
from hemp
onto the shelf
so this has been a market that's been
exploding
over the past two years you know around
two years
but now it's kind of
been pushed back with backlash from
different states for example new york
has explicitly
stated in their hemp regulations that
delta 8
is um
is not allowed to be produced and sold
in new york
so i think that's a good overview of the
regulatory environment you know right
now before i kind of open up for you
know a larger q a i just want to talk
generally about you know
entrepreneurship but i think looking at
you know large and emerging markets is a
great way to kind of start uh the
journey and seeing something that you
really have a passion for
people or
number two people are the most important
asset of any company you know bringing
in the best talent um for a variety of
different you know
factors is critical to building a you
know a long lasting business and lastly
solving a real problem you know like i
mentioned you know as i was starting
this business you know really learning
you know what the problems were of the
farmers and the processors and the
brands allowed us to kind of find our
niche
and build this business
so yeah with that said i'll you know
kind of stop here and open it up for
questions i i really appreciate
everybody's time and i'm excited to um
continue this conversation
yeah thank you for that that fantastic
talk hunter we have some questions in
the q a
um if you have a question and you
haven't put it in the q a please
do that and i will get through as many
as i can remember that the q a is
slightly different than the chat you can
access the q a from the little uh widget
at the bottom of your screen
okay first question
uh we have uh for cbd and food products
are
is it extracted from plants or can it
come from cell cultures
so
at least all the distillate or isolate
that we've purchased so well i'll kind
of take a step back all the like
the general commercially available
product on the market today
is it comes from plant material right
you grow your your hemp plant process
you take that to biomass and then
extract that and that's your kind of
core input material um that being said
in terms of
george i believe you mentioned cell
cultures right um before so i believe
that you know has some relation to you
know different genetics that can be
produced and you know cuts of different
plants to drive certain genetics
which kind of drives your biomass inputs
that being said i will kind of talk
about another you know up and coming
side of the market which is biosynthesis
where you're taking yeast
to produce cannabinoids similar to the
way that you know beer is produced today
right when you look at kind of
particularly your cheaper beers on the
shelf like a coors or a bud light you
know that is not naturally derived from
from hops those are yeast um you know
basically yeast cultured um you know
alcohol that's developed to produce that
beer so now you're seeing a lot of
technology that has been using this
biosynthesis process um to basically
manufacture um cannabinoids um
synthetic it's not really a true
synthetic synthetic process it does you
know come um you know from the plant but
that is a really up-and-coming um sector
of the industry that's really exciting
okay another question uh so the the
industry challenges that you kind of
covered um would you say those are based
on kind of the traditional
cannabis target market or has the target
market move to incorporate more general
consumers
so yeah you know my view you know
and i'll just talk cannabis industry in
general it's an ever-evolving landscape
right you know as we've seen you know
markets come online and i'll kind of
talk thc you know just starts i think
it's easier to kind of talk numbers
there's a little bit clearer data around
that
you see that in the early stages of the
markets that you know smokeable flower
and pre-rolls are the vast majority
right 55 plus percent 60 of the market
but
over time as a legal market comes in
line you start to see less and less
smokable product um or at least flower
product uh controlling the market and
more and more edible products gaining
steam vape products gaining steam
topical products gaining steam to take
up more market share where now you're
really kind of seeing almost a 50 50
split
in you know in these markets
so you know i think what we're really
developing for is kind of that sector of
the marketplace right as new consumers
jump into the space
there is you know a lack of
comfortability around smoking a product
right someone who hasn't necessarily
consumed cannabis in the past or cbd
doesn't want to necessarily start you
know smoking and adding that to their
lifestyle but adding uh you know a more
generalized product they're used to like
a beverage or you know a gel cap
or a confectionary vitamin type product
is something that there was really
generally something they do on a daily
basis
and there's not you know really a big
push to their normal lifestyle so we see
as the industry starts moving forward
and cannabis becomes you know more
accepted
that these infused products which now
represent around half the market will
continue to become um the the leader in
market share for the for the industry
so um
yeah
it's a good baseline of what we do and
yeah those
pain points we're referring to are
really revolving around infused products
and particularly water-based infused
products um you know for example a vape
is an oil-based and you wouldn't use a
water soluble product from that but
really your ingestible or topical
water-based products is you know what
we're solving uh this problem for
actually i have a question um so you've
focused a lot on kind of like cbd and
emulsions um but obviously hemp has like
tons of different uses uh specifically
like hemp seeds so i'm wondering if your
company has explored anything with like
hemp seed oil or hemp protein or you
know any people exploring that kind of
space
so you know we've definitely looked at
the space to some degree um you know
right now i think our expertise
particularly on the science side is
really relates to food science and
chemistry so more
you know on the kind of active
ingredient side of the market so you
know there's still so much
uh science to be done in that area that
we want to you know continue pushing and
tackling problems around that side of
the market um but you know generally you
know from an interest point of view i'm
super excited about you know all the
different attributes of hemp from hemp
seeds to the fiber and how that can
affect everything from
construction to clothing to you know
better uh
protein sources so you know us as a
company today um aren't really pushing
towards that side of the market but it's
something i definitely have a lot of
interest um as as well as excitement
around
great
um okay another question from the
audience uh this kind of a logistics
question given that full spectrum
distillate is likely over 0.3 thc how do
you deal with that on the legal side
yeah so you know as i mentioned the
state by state regs
um you know all have different rules but
for example in new york you know don't
quote me on it but i believe
it is up to three percent in what's
called work in progress uh hemp material
so depending on the state you'll have
you know different regulations that
qualify what you know what you can use
as a licensed manufacturer as it's not
an end you know consumer product right
so when you're looking at you know a
distillate it has to be derived from a
head plant that has less than 0.3
percent in the product that then is
extracted and you know maybe taking it
from 10 cbd
to
85 cbd so if you're at 0.1 percent thc
in the plan material now you're at just
under a percentage point but based on
new york regs you're still that's
perfectly compliant as long as the end
product
whether that be the tincture or a
beverage etc has less than 0.3 percent
delta 9 thc by weight so generally
that's that is a problem you know in the
market particularly with
you know other states not regulating
that and people crossing state lines and
certain states that still have kind of
antiquated laws around you know this
space um you know i think you've started
to see a lot of slowdown and convictions
around contempt products being crossing
state lines but you know in the kind of
2018 2019 time frame you saw you know a
lot of um
you know there's some real
issues with that as uh as you know
companies were crossing state lines with
those products but um you know in new
york uh you have clear regulator
regulations around what's allowed to be
used in the licensed supply chain so
yeah
um we have another question uh is
your uh company doing anything with
terpenes
or do you see that as a
another space in addition to
cannabinoids yeah so we're super super
excited about terpenes and you know
maybe i'll start by saying that terpenes
by nature are an oil right so our
technology is applicable to chirp means
and something that you know
personally i'm super excited about and
feel um that terpenes are really going
to be the next driver of kind of moot
states in addition to cannabinoids right
how do you drive specific
you know functions you know with the
addition of unique terpenes in
conjunction with those cannabinoids so i
think there's a lot of research to be
done in terms of what trippings do do
they do anything or not um and you know
people a lot smarter than me are the
ones kind of developing that research
and really seeing what that's what
but yeah we're starting to see at least
from the commercial side a lot more
interest of brands wanting to use
terpenes and water soluble terpenes in
their products um so it's definitely
something we're pursuing and now uh
doing rng on and now we're actually
producing water-soluble terpenes
as a product line so that's
funny that's something we've been just
just really starting to commercialize
over the past few weeks so
it's a really exciting part of the
market
very cool
um a couple questions on your um your
study to compare your kind of emulsion
to your the standard um
industry emulsion and the oil
um so when you achieve when you indicate
that you achieve better results
how would you define this quantitatively
and
have other studies kind of done like
this to
determine like
what a rapid onset means or what
extended length of effect means
yeah so you know in terms of
quantitative you know analysis there's a
couple key points right i think i
mentioned c-max right so c-max is the
highest concentration um in the
bloodstream that's recorded in one of
these pk studies so from a basic level
we compared the c-max of our emulsion to
the c-max of the basic emulsion to the
c-max of the oil tincture and showed
that you know ours was 30 minutes the
basic emulsion was 70 minutes and the
oil tincture was you know 180 plus
minutes um didn't really ever reach you
know a full peak
um over the course of like four hours or
so
so um yeah that's like generally
quantitatively how we're
um testing that in addition to just
seeing when it shows up in the
bloodstream as you saw on that graph you
know those are actual results from the
rat study that have said okay at this
interval in time there was this many
milligrams
in the bloodstream you know versus these
other product types so again you know
this is just the first of many studies
that we plan to do
and um and yeah
our next study is going to be around a
dog model hopefully one day around a
human model and you know comparing to
some of the the competition the space i
think exactly what you mentioned where
there's a lack of real evidence is uh is
why we decided to invest in these quite
expensive studies but we feel that it's
really important to actually have real
data behind what we're doing as opposed
to just making claims of we have fast
onset time or we have an onset time of
five minutes or two minutes and we're a
high bioavailability which we see a lot
of the competition in the space do uh
but those claims are kind of backed by
by nothing um which again we feel is a
big problem and as you see more
sophisticated consumer package goods
companies and to come into the space
they're really going to be looking for
this hard evidence from an efficacy
point of view as well as from a
stability point of view so you know
that's really what we're building up to
right now is trying to build as big of a
book of evidence as possible getting
ready for future fda regulation
another question on that study
so how how would you expect the
levels in the model system to correlate
to
humans
do you know what levels of cbd are
required to achieve
uh physiologically significant effects
so um you know again i'm not that's not
the the full-on scientist i've learned
slowly by doing here you know with great
people around us uh i believe the rat
model is a great indicator of what it
can look like in mammalian model again
what we're doing to push forward
is then moving up the next chain to a
dog and then one day doing a human um
but then again the cost associated with
you know doing these more complicated
models or significantly increasing even
going from the rat to the dog and dog to
humans
so it's definitely something that that
we plan to do you know as the company
develops
um
in terms of like what is an efficacious
dose i think that's uh
you know a big um not just a controversy
but a big talking point in the industry
right for example in new york it's 25
milligrams max per unit in the food and
beverage product so
the question is is does that actually is
that a real applications dose what is
navigation status but as a placebo
effect versus not you know i can talk
from you know the one approved
pharmaceutical drug in the market called
epidialex
that's a a drug used for children with
epilepsy those doses range to from 600
to 2000 plus milligrams so that's what
we're seeing is like a true
pharmaceutical dose
that being said for more of your
wellness
doses what we see in the market is
somewhere in the range of 25 to 100
milligrams with you know regulations
kind of limiting your food and beverage
products at 25 milligram per unit base
so again i think that's where there's
opportunities in the space to just kind
of push
science and learn more invest more money
and research
as we continue to develop out again
that's another issue just with the fda
right the lack of regulation with space
is really limiting research around you
know
what does the what do these cannabinoids
actually do and you know what do we need
uh
and how much do we need to take etc so i
hope that's a just an answer for you
um
another question uh people are very
interested in the study that you did uh
are you looking to kind of explore or
conduct studies on um
on
like pregnant mice or pregnant rats um
and they they point out that it might be
important for regulations because this
is a specifically vulnerable
uh population
to be honest i never uh never even
thought about that i think i'll bring
that up with nick as we move into our
our next study i know our next one is
definitely going to be in a dog model um
but you know as you move forward just
trying to again build up a book of
evidence and kind of anticipating what
the fda regulations look like i think i
saw something in the q a chat box about
novel foods
one of the big things that we want to do
is a toxicity study right you know
that's a really really expensive study
upwards of potentially a 500 000 plus
study
um
so and that's uh you know that's that's
what we want to get to but right now
with lack of rules uh and knowing what
we need to even test for um at least in
the us it's hard to make those
investments so you know again right now
we're kind of taking it one step at a
time and trying to build up as much
evidence as possible
you know while keeping costs under
control
awesome
another question
have you been able to export your
cannabinoid ingredients to europe and do
you have novel foods authorization
so we don't have novel foods opposite
authorization just yet something that
we've been looking into um that being
said you know we will be announcing the
next couple weeks
our entrance into the southeast asian
market we're going to be entering the
thai market through a licensing deal
thailand has really clear regulations
around the use of cbd in products now
it's a fully legal market there so we
will be working with an operator on the
ground in thailand to bring our
technology to that market so that'll be
our first
international expansion
we'll be into thailand and the southeast
asian market so we're really excited
about that this is the first uh
time i've talked about it publicly so
exciting to talk about that
very cool i think we'll
just do one more question here and wrap
it up i know you probably put you
through the ringer these last 15 minutes
i love it
so uh we got one more uh have you done
stability testing on your products and
what kind of shelf life range have you
seen
yeah so our our products have stayed on
the shelf for well over a year and i've
shown really great um stability you know
less than a few percentage points of
degradation um you know again what we do
is a couple different paths so we left
their products on the shelf they have
true stability of you know actual time
you know in a product as well as just an
ingredient on the shelf there's nothing
better than that stability test there's
also rapid stability where you can use
heated chambers to
anticipate um you know a quicker time so
maybe a month can look like a year from
a stability point of view and just
different stability chambers and then
the last way that we go about stability
tested is using a unique rapid stability
equipment where we you know basically
test um you know infused product and see
basically spin it really fast and light
particles through it to kind of
anticipate how stable is something
really quickly so as opposed to even
taking a month or two months sitting on
the shelf and in a you know heated
chamber we can tell in a matter of hours
um you know generally how physically
stable
our emulsion is with a certain product
type and that goes to kind of a
customization but that's uh how uh you
know the three ways we go about
stability testing and restability you
know wrap do a rapid stability test on
any product for forage commercialized to
get that that baseline at a minimum
so
i want to thank you once again hunter
for that wonderful talk i sure learned a
lot and it was fascinating to see your
perspective and experience
um i i believe that
many of our attendees feel the same way
so uh you know best of luck to you and
thanks again for all of your time and it
was it was a real pleasure to
hear your talk
thank you so much everybody again my
contact information is here please feel
free to to reach out and um looking
forward to
continuing this and
again thank you everybody
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu